this altitude this podcast is brought to
you by Hugh is in human H you Hugh Hugh
founded by family tree Oh Jason Karp his
wife Jessica and his brother-in-law
Jordan brown started off as a paleo
inspired restaurant New York City in
2012 I actually came across that
restaurant when I was doing a book
launch staying at the Ace Hotel and
thought to myself this is the best place
I've ever found in New York City it's
just incredible and now they make
amazing plant-based healthy snacks
including their award-winning paleo /
vegan dark chocolate I discovered the
chocolate a few years ago and got
totally hooked on my podcast road trip
to current state prison I was going to
do a podcast behind the wall inside a
maximum-security prison which I did at
the time Jason Karp the co-founder I
mentioned Peter Tia and others were all
in the same car and Jason brought a case
of huge chocolate for our for our ride I
ate a ton of these bars at least four of
these bars in one sitting and I didn't
crash which was sort of miraculous to me
maybe it's because for instance their
simple bar has only three ingredients
organic cacao organic cacao butter and
organic coconut sugar without any soy or
other junk or maybe it's just because I
was timing them out and eating one bar
every 30 minutes in any case since then
and because I love their products and
their philosophy I've become an advisor
to you and I've also tried everything
their honks which are chocolate covered
nuts and berries the almonds are my
favorite if you're looking there that's
one of my favorites and their grain free
keto friendly crackers their stuff is
simply delicious and deliciously simple
they really really pay attention to
quality their tagline is get back to
human because they believe people can
feel and perform better when they eat
foods with cleaner simpler
less processed and less industrial
ingredients they avoid emulsifiers palm
oil dairy soy or sunflower lecithin
sugar alcohol as a whole list and
everything is certified gluten-free
kosher and non-gmo so pretty much if you
are trying to avoid something that bugs
you it has already been taken off the
table and the most important thing to
remember is their stuff is delicious
absolutely delicious I really recommend
you try them out and you can get 15% off
your hue order again that's hu your hue
order by visiting hue kitchen com
forward slash Tim hu kitchen dot-com
forward slash Tim and using discount
code to him at checkout t IM make haste
their holiday shipping cutoff is
December 18th and these are perfect for
the holidays I'm telling you these are
the most delicious chocolate bars I've
ever had and I'll get to what I
recommend
so get 15% off by visiting hue kitchen
com forward slash Tim and entering
discount code Tim T I am at checkout and
on that page so go if you want to see
one of my favorites go to hue kitchen
come forward slash Tim you will see a
number of things including the nut
butters gift box and this includes a
number of different bars that have nut
butter in side these chocolate squares
you can't cashew butter plus vanilla
bean that is the one that I had four
bars of on this car right you get almond
butter plus puffed quinoa nothing add
another two to four of those on that
ride then hazelnut butter and cashew
butter plus raspberry but these things
are amazing you will not be disappointed
so check it out go to Hue kitchen comm
forward slash Tim and use promo code Tim
to get 15% off
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is Tim Ferriss welcome to another
episode of the Tim Ferriss show where it
is usually my job to sit down with
world-class performers of all different
types startup founders investors chess
champions Olympic athletes you name it
to tease out the habits that you can
apply in your own lives this episode
however is an experiment and part of a
short-form series that I'm doing simply
called books I've loved I've invited
some amazing past guests close friends
and new faces to share their favorite
books describe their favorite books the
books that have influenced them changed
them transform them for the better and I
hope you pick up one or two new mentors
in the form of books from this new
series and apply the lessons in your own
life I had a lot of fun putting this
together inviting these people to
participate and have learned so so much
myself I hope that is also the case for
you please enjoy hey it's Seth Seth
goden I'm an author and entrepreneur a
blogger and a teacher I've written 19
best-selling books packaged 120 others
but the most effective project I've
created is the alt MBA I'm here to honor
Tim and a half a billion and to talk
about a bunch of books that have stuck
with me through the years I want to
start and end with particularly profound
ones but each one matters a lot to me
and I think it will resonate with the
people who are listening to this so
let's get going the gift by Lewis Hyde
we gave the gift to many of the first
thousand or 2,000 people who took the
author MBA the gift is a dense
extraordinarily researched book written
by a brilliant writer and it's not about
what you think it's about it's not about
reciprocity it's not about the hustle
it's not about giving gifts so you will
get things it's about the Meuse about
being a genius it's about culture and
it's about society it's about the fact
that the thing that binds us together
isn't trade nor is it as Graber would
say
dad no the thing that binds us together
is the fact that we are able to create
something because we got a gift from who
knows where and that we could turn that
thing we created into a connection we
can do it by sharing and as we share
with one another we open doors for other
people and every once in a while I feel
a little bit burnt out I'll open up any
section of the gift to read about the
shoemaker to read about Calvin to read
about genius to read about potlatch and
it will stick with me next on my list is
a book written by Tom Peters that most
people have not read it's called the
pursuit of Wow from 1994 I met Tom in 84
right after in search of excellence came
out it was just a random connection but
ever since then I have been inspired and
amazed by his energy and by his passion
and this book captures so much of it you
don't have to read many of the books
I've written if you just read the
pursuit of wow what tom is talking about
in this book and he's not afraid to use
exclamation points underlines bold and
the occasional illustration or photo is
that people who care can make a
difference and that business as usual
just isn't going to cut it any more as
Tom Peters would say make it excellent
period thank you Tom for showing me that
putting energy into the work really can
pay dividends after that three books to
share that have basic concepts in them
that once you see them you cannot unsee
them the first one is a book I wish I
had written darn many books I haven't
written that I wish I had written and
this is one of them the long tale by
Chris Anderson you may have heard about
it but you probably haven't read the
book as closely as you might if you care
about how ideas spread in our culture
and you want to understand issues around
scarcity and abundance about how we pick
what we want in an era when the
gatekeepers have left the building
well the longtail will help you see it
the idea that the power-law curve really
is symmetrical the idea that people who
a great many many choices has so many of
the behemoths in social media have done
are building something that's going to
continue to change the culture the
second one also based on a curve is
crossing the chasm by Jeff Moore
there are many editions of this book I
like the older editions but that's just
cause I'm a Boomer but crossing the
chasm helps us understand that it is a
myth an incorrect myth a false myth to
believe that we can start with an idea
for a few people and ride it from early
adopter to early majority to late
majority to laggard that in fact there
is a chasm there is a hole in that hole
fell the Apple Newton which you probably
don't even remember it turns out the
Newton was a success when it first came
out that they sold a hundred thousand of
them in the first month or two and then
it hit the wall and then it went away
and the reason it went away is it fell
into the chasm and you need to see the
chasm be prepared for the chasm walk
into the chasm knowing that getting to
the other side is a lot more difficult
than it looks
or you can happily dance with the early
adopters one thing that's fascinating
about Tim's career is what a great job
he did from the very first book of going
from the geeks the Nerds the early
adopters who were hacking their
lifestyle all the way across the chasm
to a half a billion downloads and the
third strategy book is called thinking
in bets by Annie Duke yes that Annie
Duke World Poker champion and the first
chapter alone will change your life
thinking in bets helps us understand
what it actually means to make a
decision because decisions and outcomes
are different things
and a good decision may very well lead
to allow the outcome that doesn't mean
it wasn't a good decision two more books
and then I'll let you go back to hacking
your lifestyle these books touched me at
an emotional level in my book your turn
I tried to capture some of this energy
but the women who wrote these two books
can do it far better than I ever could
the first one is a poem it's now in a
new format I published it in its
original format it's a poem called B and
it's by Sarah Kay the one and only Sarah
K spoken word maestro you can see her
TED talk it's the only TED talk I've
ever seen that was interrupted by a
standing ovation B is a simple poem from
a mother to her daughter and I have to
confess I get choked up every single
time I read it if you've got a mother or
if you've got a daughter this is a great
gift a great book to share with them and
the last book I'll talk about is by a
woman who has changed my life since the
day I met her her name is Jacqueline
Novogratz the book is the blue sweater
her next book is coming out early 2020 I
hope you'll look for it the blue sweater
is the true story of how one woman has
decided to change philanthropy
capitalism development and the way two
billion poor people who just happened to
be poor they don't deserve to be poor
two billion people who are currently
poor engage with markets engage with the
privileged part of the world and engage
with each other the blue sweater begins
with an astonishing story about just how
small our world is when Jacqueline was
growing up I believe it was in Virginia
she used to wear this sweater her uncle
had given her it was a blue sweater that
had some mountain ranges needle pointed
on it well after being humiliated in
high school she and her mom brought it
to the goodwill box and dumped it in
there fast-forward 10 years later she is
jogging in Rwanda at six o'clock in the
more
and she sees a kid across the street in
Rwanda she chases the kid down the
street which must have been frightening
indeed catches up to him grabs him by
the collar and looks on the inside of
the sweater and they're written in
marker is her name all the way across
the world this world we live in it
doesn't have enough dignity it doesn't
have enough connection that the gifts we
share need to be based on abundance it's
not I don't have it because you have it
it's now we both have it and what the
acumen fund has done is built a
different model of how people can engage
with one another to make change happen
so that's my list of books books about
strategy books about inspiration books
about how we live our lives but one
thing that I have learned from a
lifetime of being in the book business
is that the book business isn't a
business it's a passion and an organized
hobby it's a chance for just 20 bucks to
own something that you can keep on your
shelf and go back to again and again
there's a pristine reaction I have when
I see a book it's not the same when it's
on audio or a Kindle but I don't care
how you consume these ideas I just hope
that you do and then that you live them
and share them because seeing the world
as it is and then choosing to make it
better I don't know what more we could
ask for it thanks for listening to me
today go make your ruckus
hi I'm Esther Perel I'm a
psychotherapist an author a TED speaker
and a podcast host if you haven't read
my books mating in captivity or the
state of affairs you may actually
recognize my voice from my podcast where
should we begin where I bring you into
my office to listen in on real-life
couples therapy sessions or my newest
Spotify project housework which brings
lessons from Kapaa therapy to the corner
office all my work involves helping
individuals couples co-founders family
members colleagues deal with the hidden
dimensions of the hidden forces that
underlie relationship dynamics because I
believe that it is the quality of our
relationships that determines the
quality of our lives and that
cultivating relational intelligence
today is a new bottom line and certainly
in the workplace I'm here to honor Tim
who's been a friend and a most wonderful
collaborator and all his many listeners
and I want to share with you a few books
that have shaped the way I think about
relational intelligence I've
deliberately chosen books actually that
have very little to do with the business
world I come from psychology I work as a
psychologist but every one of these
books is going to give you or at least
has given me tremendous insight into our
life both at home at work and I would
say in our society at large because I
work with people who are in situations
that are highly contentious groups
individuals teams co-founders the book
of Marshall Rosenberg nonviolent
communication a language of life has
been really a classic it's actually a
book that doesn't age but the reason
that book spoke to me is because as a
child of true Holocaust survivors have
often lived with this one question or in
fact not often I think this question has
followed me my whole life what is it
that disconnects us from our
compassionate nature and leads us to
behave violently and exploitative Lee
but on the other end what is it that
allows some people to stay connected to
their compassionate nature in the most
challenging of circumstances the way
that that this book highlights the
importance of language the speaking and
the listening the language that suits
and repairs and the language that
creates ruptures that are often beyond
repair I think that this book is a
classic for anyone who is thinking
relationships fighting for your marriage
by Howard Markman Scott Stanley and
Susan Bloomberg on its surface it's a
book about marriage of course but you
just go one layer deeper and it's a
study of the underlying issues that
shape the way that we relate both with
my couples and my corporate clients I
quite often pull from mark man's
theories to assess what's really going
on behind the manifest and it's very
simple to capture is this underneath
many of the relational impasses or
conflicts you're going to find three
major dynamics a fight about power and
control
a fight about care and closeness and a
fight about respect and recognition so
it's either about power about trust or
about integrity I think that those three
dimensions pretty much stand at the helm
of our relational life so that book will
help many people personally as well as
professionally can love last the fit of
romance over time by Stephen Mitchell
Mitchell's book was part of the spine of
my book mating in captivity because he
highlighted an inherent tension that
spoke a great deal to me and it's the
tension in how we try today to reconcile
in one relationship two fundamental sets
of human needs the need for stability
our need for safety for security
together with the need for change
passion novelty and mystery these two
sets of needs that he describes so well
that spring from different sources and
also pull us in different directions how
we straddle security and adventure
tradition and change familiarity and
novelty comfort and edge I think today
is a central challenge
for couples as well as for companies
it's a little philosophical book it
really requires sitting but it's a gem
of a book and he died an untimely debt
at 53 and so in many ways I have often
found that I was able to give voice to
some of these ideas posthumously every
one of the books that I'm thinking here
are books that really shaped my thinking
they shifted a paradigm for me I came
one way and I finished the book and left
another way and zygmunt bauman spoke
liquid life is another one like that
his description of nomadism gave me a
whole new path of thinking because he
looks at nomadism as this thread of our
liquid life where we flow through life
like a tourist where we change places
and jobs and spouses and values
including our religious in our
professional affiliations what he
highlights is how we've dismantled the
traditional structures and networks that
used to give us support and now we live
in a precarious life under conditions of
constant uncertainty where the burdens
of the self have never been heavier I
would be remiss if I didn't bring in my
own mentor salvador minuchin who was the
founder of structural family therapy
came from theories of communications and
systems thinking because it is probably
the foundation of much of my thinking
you can read family healing you can read
structural family therapy which is the
real theoretical basis of it it will
change your whole way of understanding
relationships but I think what it really
did for me is I used to come and think
about problems from a individualistic
point of view and he gave me a map for
thinking about relationships
systemically tracking the invisible
rules that govern the maps of
relationship between people how do we
actually go about disrupting
dysfunctional relationship patterns be
they couples or families or in
organizations and how do we help people
switch them to healthier ones this idea
that pathology isn't necessarily inside
the person but created by
happens between the two people or the
idea that in relationships it's easy to
look for a villain and a victim but it
isn't necessarily so what I can say is
that every one of these books is in my
mind when I do the sessions for house
work
it is how I think it is what leads me to
do the interventions that I do and I
hope that you will enjoy these books as
much as I do I thank you for listening
and I would like to just ask you a
couple of relational intelligence
questions what are some of the stories
that you tell yourself that don't serve
you anymore
give me a time when you changed your
mind
what would you say is the best piece of
advice that you've ever received would
you say that you were raised more for
autonomy or for loyalty enjoy the
readings and enjoy the conversations hey
guys this is Tim again just a few more
things before you take off number one
this is five bullet Friday do you want
to get a short email from me would you
enjoy getting a short email from me
every Friday event provides a little
morsel of fun before the weekend and 500
Friday is a very short email where I
share the coolest things I've found or
that I've been pondering over the week
that could include favorite new albums
that I've discovered it could include
gizmos and gadgets and all sorts of
weird [ __ ] that I've somehow dug up in
the the world of the esoteric as I do it
could include a favorite articles that I
have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com that's four hour work week com
all spelled out and just drop in your
and you will get the very next one and
if you sign up I hope you enjoy it
this podcast is brought to you by Hugh
as in human h uq q founded by family
trio jason Karp his wife Jessica and his
brother-in-law Jordan brown started off
as a paleo inspired restaurant New York
City in 2012 I actually came across that
restaurant when I was doing a book
launch staying at a hotel and flopped
myself this is the best place I've ever
found in New York City it's just
incredible and now they make amazing
plant-based healthy snacks including
their award-winning paleo / vegan dark
chocolate I discovered the chocolate a
few years ago and got totally hooked on
my podcast road trip to current state
prison I was going to do a podcast
behind the wall inside a
maximum-security prison which I did at
the time Jason Karp the co-founder I
mentioned Peter Tia and others were all
in the same car and Jason brought a case
of huge chocolate for our for our pride
I ate a ton of these bars at least four
of these bars in one sitting and it
didn't crash which was sort of
miraculous to me
maybe it's because for instance their
simple bar has only three ingredients
organic cacao organic cacao butter and
organic coconut sugar without any soy or
other junk or maybe it's just because I
was timing them out and eating one bar
every thirty minutes in any case since
then and because I love their products
and their philosophy I become an advisor
to you and I've also tried every their
hunks which are chocolate covered nuts
and berries the almonds are my favorite
if we're looking there that's one of my
favorites and their grain free keto
friendly crackers their stuff is simply
delicious and deliciously simple they
really really pay attention to quality
their tagline is get back to human
because they believe people can feel and
perform better when they eat foods
cleaner simpler less processed and less
industrial ingredients they avoid
emulsifiers palm oil dairy soy or
sunflower lecithin
sugar alcohols hold
and everything is certified gluten-free
kosher and non-gmo so pretty much if you
are trying to avoid something that bugs
you it has already been taken off the
table and the most important thing to
remember is their stuff is delicious
absolutely delicious I really recommend
you try them out and you can get 15% off
your hue order again that's hu your hue
order by visiting Q kitchen comport /
Tim hu kitchen calm / Tim and using
discount code Tim at checkout TI m they
cased their holiday shipping cutoff is
December 18 and these are perfect for
the holidays I'm telling you these are
the most delicious chocolate bars I have
ever had and I'll get what I recommend
so get 50% off by visiting Q kitchen
compote / Tim and entering discount code
Tim GIM at checkout and on that page so
go if you want to see one of my
favorites going Hugh kitchen calm / /
Tim you will see a number of things
including the nut butters gift box and
this includes a number of different bars
that have nut butter inside these
chocolate squares you get cashew butter
+ vanilla bean that is the one that I
had four bars of on this car right you
get almond butter + puffed quinoa they
got another two to four of those on that
alright then hazelnut butter and cashew
butter + raspberry but these things are
amazing you will not be disappointed so
check it out go to Q kitchen calm / /
Tim and use promo code Tim to get 15%
off
[Applause]
you